[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man and spider-man
no way the trailer has been released
after 84 years we have our first full
look at the movie and in this video
we're going to be breaking down the
easter eggs things you missed and
discussing all the plot points and
comics that it pulls from it's been
living in my head rent-free like peter
parker and i'm so happy to talk about it
so let's just get into it now you start
off with peter and mj sitting on a
rooftop this is something that has
happened at several points in the comics
and films and i got a lot of vibes here
of the original spider-man 3 in which
the pair both sat stargazing we learned
that this is in the aftermath of peter's
identity being made public but looks
like at this point that he's managed to
clear his name even if everyone now
knows it mj is reading a newspaper from
the new york post and not the daily
bugle as we learned that in the mcu it
was an alex jones-esque show rather than
a publication on the front cover it
reads peter parker and his spider
minions with him puppeting people
showing that the media is still sort of
trashing him even though he saved the
city and also the universe gonna put
some dirt in their eyes and it also
shows that those around him have been
pulled into it too which we'll talk
about later on in the video now mj reads
one of the passages out about how some
suggest parker's powers include the
ability to hypnotize females whilst this
is thrown away as a little joke it
actually foreshadows the big reveal in
the trailer in which peter asks strange
to pretty much hypnotize the entire
world into forgetting that he's
spider-man peter just wants to stay up
there forever and then we cut to him and
mj swinging through the streets of new
york in the aftermath of the
post-credits scene from far from home
peter's face is blown up all over times
square with the mask superimposed onto
one side this iconography pulls from the
comics namely when his spider sense is
set off and it's also very similar to
some of the promo material which showed
his face split between strangers we
later see a shot in which people swamp
him at a subway entrance and judging by
the location of this shot i would say
that this is how the movie opens the
street sign says west 33rd street which
according to google maps is opposite
pennsylvania station which is where
peter was at during the post-credits in
that movie from what we know of the film
the opening is very much going to be in
the same vein as john wick 3 and it'll
see spider-man being chased across new
york as this revelation breaks the
internet we occur to him in the police
station trying to explain the drones and
how they are what killed mysterio even
though he was put in charge of edith
peter also sits with handcuffs on which
reminds me a lot of man of steel when
superman was being interrogated he could
clearly snap out of them in a second but
he's left them on for appearance's sake
now there's a guy who slams down some
papers in a split second shot and it
looks a lot like matt murdock from the
shirt to the tie we do know that charlie
cox will be in the movie and this is a
blink and you'll miss a moment that i'm
99 sure is him the one percent is
because i asked a mate who said it
definitely wasn't him so tell him to
shut the hell up in the comments if he's
wrong because i bloody hate the guy for
disagreeing with me now we could to him
and mj reading their phones which
clearly have headlines and reports about
the revelation i love how this and the
opening of the trailer are pretty much
them obsessing over the news reports and
it shows how much it being out there has
completely dominated their lives peter
wanting to just stay on the roof away
from everyone shows how much he feels
deep down that it's changed things for
the worst and it nicely sets up the
actions that he takes also i love how mj
has sketches of people hanging above her
bed and this is something that she of
course did during detention in
homecoming next we get what is clearly a
flashback in which the character likely
handed himself in or was taken to court
we see someone as a sign that says devil
in disguise
and mephisto confirmed
now here he's joined by ned mj and what
i think is flash thompson who has dyed
his hair blonde in the comics the
character was blonde and it's nice to
see him supporting peter flash was
obviously a massive spider-man fan but
ironically he hated peter and also
bullied him the reveal has obviously
changed things and it will be
interesting to see if reversing this
knowledge turns him back into being a
baddie next we cut to what i believe is
immediately after the event so far from
home in which both peter and mj are
getting followed through new york from
here we jump to him in school and bro i
cannot believe he went back there you
know what i'm somewhat of an idiot
myself and i definitely definitely
wouldn't be returning there mate steer
clear now we can also see the back of
some letterman jackets and ned could be
caught wearing one of these in the
recently released funko pop picks for
the film the m on it likely stands for
midtown high which is what peter
attended in the comics spoiler alert now
we see peter and may sat in their
apartment and from this shot i almost
get the feeling like someone has walked
in on them from the way that she sits up
peter says that this isn't about him
it's hurting the people he loves and as
batman said the mask is to protect those
around you now this might be pulling
slightly from the civil war comic as
that had peter revealing his identity to
the world in order to show that the
superhuman registration act was
something worth doing peter was very
much the eyes and ears of the reader and
over time he changed his mind and went
on the run his arc actually ended with
ant-may getting shot which plays into
the one more day storyline that we'll
talk about in a bit either way you very
much get the idea that the reveal of his
name has led to people around him being
put in danger and it'll be interesting
to see if they lean into what happens
with mae in that especially as we don't
really see her in the rest of the
trailer now along with may ned 2 gets
questioned by the police and it's clear
that a lot of people want to know when
the announcement that toby and andrew
are in the movie is gonna drop just tell
us yeah just tell us and there won't be
a problem now from this trailer we can
also confirm that the film will be
spanning a lot of seasons as we catch
peter in a classroom with halloween
decorations hanging up cut back to when
he and mj were sat in their room and we
could see christmas lights we also know
from behind the scenes videos that peter
is going to be in the snow at some point
so i would say that this movie takes
place over at least the span of six
months judging from when far from home
happened and the decoration around the
sets now hilariously pierre comes up
with the idea to go and see doctor
strange by looking at the hanging wizard
lights that are in the aforementioned
room he journeys to the sanctum
sanctorum which we can see covered in
snow and why this likely is is because
bruce banner blew a big hole in the roof
during the opening of infinity war
right after this strange was at the very
least snapped away and the fact that it
took a while to get it fixed might
confirm that one was too during this
time the elements have taken over and we
can now catch him shoveling snow but bro
thought you could use magic bro you set
a fireplace on fire bruh just melt it
and do that thing you didn't end game
just just do that with the water now a
strange nba have a nice little back and
forth in which they talk over what to
address each other as this of course
plays on the first time that they met in
which they used their made-up names
strange's mug says for [ __ ] sake which
sort of makes me think he's thinking
that seeing peter show up on his
doorstep anyway the web head has one
request and that is to remove the
knowledge from everyone's head that
peter parker is spider-man now as
mentioned earlier this is clearly
pulling from the comic book storyline
one more day in which he went to strange
in order to help save aunt may strange
even lived in a run down and boarded up
santorum during this and he helped him
to travel through multiple timelines so
that he could see if there was anyone
who could help
unfortunately everyone said that there
was nothing they could do and thus he
ended up turning to mephisto and this
idea of traveling through timelines
could potentially be seen in the trailer
as peter asks if he can go back in time
or something and strange levitates at
one point in a position that looks
similar to what he did in infinity war
now if we are right with this then it
clearly doesn't work as strange has to
carry out a different spell and as
endgame showed us all that travelling
back would do would be to create a
branched reality in the comics no one
was able to help peter and he ended up
making a deal with mephisto and along
with bringing mae back he also removed
the knowledge from everyone's mind that
peter was spider-man this was so that
people wouldn't come after me again and
in exchange for doing this mephisto made
it so that peter and mj never got
married now the fact that strange is the
one carrying out the spell and not the
devil who's always in the details makes
me think he won't actually be showing up
in the mcu for a long time yes i know it
was obvious i just i was just holding
out hope that one of the fan theories
would be right and everything i said in
one division wasn't for nothing now in
between this scene we hear peter
explaining to strange why it's really
important that this happens and amongst
the shots of him getting swamped which
we talked about earlier jump to wong who
warns strange not to cast the spell and
he promises not to even though he gives
peter a cheeky little wink interestingly
wong packs his bags and leaves and from
what we've seen of the shangchi trailer
this might actually be him going off to
fight the abomination kevin feige has
confirmed that he is indeed in the film
i like that we kind of watch him walking
off whilst this happens now if you're
enjoying the video so far then i'd
massively appreciate the thumbs up and
also don't forget to subscribe as we do
breakdowns like this each and every day
and it just makes spider sense to stick
around that ran free like peter parker
joke yeah that deserves a thumbs up at
the very least you know it does now now
anyway back in the trailer and we watch
strange use one of peter's hairs in the
men and black memory eraser spell lately
something like this is needed in order
to tie your spell to someone and the
character pinched some hair from thor in
ragnarok before sending him and his
brother off to me odin now if you've
been following the channel then you'll
know we talked about this moment in our
last plot league video and it looks like
peter interrupting the spell is what
causes reality to break open he doesn't
want his girlfriend or people like mate
to forget he's spider-man and thus he
knocks strange's concentration off
slightly in order to stipulate this
earlier in the trailer peter does say
that he feels bad about lying to mj so
it does make sense why this would
suddenly spring to mind now if toby and
andrew are indeed in the film which yeah
worst kept secret of all time then this
moment could be a call back to the happy
birthday storyline in that dormammu
attacked new york and doctor strange
cast a spell which peter interrupted
this split up in time itself and he was
able to view a future version of himself
as well as a past one he was able to
interact and change events so we might
even see a moment in which peter stops
the broadcast with mysterio either way
this spell seemingly works but we also
get what looks like a rainbow bridge
amongst it being cast over the world
this effect is typically shown when
someone is traveling through the bifrost
so maybe at this point a villain comes
across the multiverse and into the mcu
weirdly this effect was actually used in
a number of fake fan made trailers so
give yourself a pat on the back if you
did that you spoiled the trailer and you
got it right well done now there are
several villains that i counted in this
first look or at least teases to them
this is obviously the first look and
sony don't want to blow their load but
from what i saw and what we know of the
film the rumors and reports are true
it's true
all of it and the first big one is of
course alfred molina's doctor octopus
who arrives at the end of the trailer
and says hello peter
during one of the many quick cuts was
that that was a really bad i should have
re-recorded that but moving on now
molina has pretty much taken the mantle
of the spoiler man from tom holland and
he's been out and about telling us
everything that happens in the movie
according to him we see a scene in which
an alternate version of the character at
the end of spider-man 2 is pulled across
the multiverse through a portal if you
catch your mind back to that film the
villain died after drowning a miniature
sun in the hudson and it's possible that
when this collapsed that it pulled him
across william defoe's green goblin is
also teased when a pumpkin bomb rolls
towards the screen we've been saying for
months now that he's in the film and
that he will end up forming the sinister
six you also see some electrical sparks
and know from jamie foxx that he will be
reprising his role as electro though his
costume will be different at the end of
the amazing spider-man fox was
overcharged and he was seemingly killed
though they may explain that this sent
him off into an alternate reality
peter's black and gold suit has been
heavily shown in the toys and
promotional material and judging by the
circuitry on it this will be used to
fight the electrical enemy now they may
pull from this they may not but from
what i've been told the majority of the
characters are what if versions in which
their arcs differ slightly so if you
still like the versions from the
original films then that isn't going to
be rude for you we also see a pile of
sand rising up in the trailer as well as
the lizard from the amazing spider-man 2
jumping up at peta whilst it's in a
glass prison now i will be doing some
minor spoilers here just talking about
the context of this shot from what the
leaks say but i know some of you don't
want to know anything so if you don't
want this rune then swing out the video
but i promise you i'll just be providing
info on the scenes and nothing really
beyond that as always take these with a
pinch of salt as they might not come
true but the trailer does line up a lot
with what i've been told so you have
been warned now strange apparently
imprisons the villains in this after
they cause chaos across new york whilst
he tries to figure out a way to send
them back william defoe's norman osborne
shows up to ask about their lives and
they say the last thing they remember
was spider-man unable to free them
because of the powerful magic osborne
goes to peter and pleased with him to
help out and he tells him that these
characters will die if they're returned
home he also says that the peter of
their world was there when they passed
away and tom holland's version is racked
with guilt because he could potentially
be sending them back to their deaths so
he breaks into strange's prison and
steals a magical cube that's holding
them in place we see this in the trailer
and strange supposedly chases peter
across new york in the mirror dimension
this is why we get a big chase scene and
also see the city falling in on itself
at one point like inception the effect
of course appeared in the first doctor
strange movie and it's gonna make for an
amazing scene from what we get in the
trailer it looks absolutely outstanding
i think it's going to blow a lot of
people's minds watching this in imax
there's also a big chase on a train and
it's clear that strange doesn't mind
throwing everything he can including
uncharted 2 directly at him in order to
stop him breaking the multiverse strange
clearly catches up to peter at one point
and he pushes his astral projection out
of his body which is also something that
the ancient one did to the incredible
hulk now from what strange says about
double lives i kinda get the feeling
that peter might actually be attempting
to flip back and forth between mj
knowing who he is and also forgetting
potentially the spell broke reality and
him constantly doing this might be why
strange says the things that he does
about living two lives you also see what
could potentially be miles morales
mother and if you cast your mind back to
the title reveal you'll remember that
the surrounding lines looked a lot like
the island puerto rico so it could be
teasing his introduction here other
shots include the upgraded iron spider
suit which carries a slightly different
design to what it had in infinity war to
me this looks more in line with the
civil war version that was in the comics
but they've also made it at least line
up with what's come before now if we
look at the happy birthday storyline it
actually culminates with peter fighting
his entire rogue's gallery across a
number of timelines this obviously lends
itself to the concept of no way home and
i would definitely recommend checking
out that book if you want some comics
that the movie will probably pull from
at the end of it strange gives peter
parker a present and he opens it to find
that it actually brings uncle ben back
to him for a few moments the pair talk
about peter's life and have a really
amazing conversation that will bring
tears to your eyes no not me not me
though i'm solid as [ __ ] me now another
interesting aspect of the novel is that
it ends with doctor strange realizing
that by breaking the multiverse he's
caused a lot of problems in the magical
world it very much teases that he'll be
facing off against several sorcerers and
potentially this could be what happens
with wander it was said that loki no way
home and in the multiverse of madness
will all be part of the same storyline i
think it makes a lot of sense judging
from the way that the comic ends that
he'll be going toe-to-toe with her
though we don't know for definite
whether wonder's gonna be a villain i
actually think that you will and yeah
i'd love to see the scarlet witch go
ahead with strange
now as for the first look as a whole
it's got me really excited for the film
i genuinely think this movie will do big
numbers at the box office and had the
pandemic not been in the way i would
have estimated that this could have come
very close to the 2 billion mark marvel
and sony weren't kidding when they said
that this would be tom holland's end
game and it's the culmination of several
franchises and films that started out 20
years ago there's a lot resting on its
shoulders but i fully trust everyone on
board with the project to deliver
something big and bombastic this is
definitely the best movie since end game
for me and outside of the batman there's
nothing that i'm just hyped for it's
gonna break the internet and might even
break christmas if they manage to pull
it off and it also releases then the
first look was a testament to that and i
am very hyped for it right now to me
this did the perfect job of being a
first trailer as it didn't go too over
the top in completely spoiling
everything and it just teased some of
the bigger elements that will be
happening in the movie however it also
gave us enough info on what the story
could be so that we can go wild with fan
theories and yeah i'm just so hyped
after checking out this first trailer
for the film the action is great the
soundtrack is great the ominous feeling
and be careful what you wish for tone
works really well and it reminds us that
peter parker never has it easy overall
i'm super hyped and yeah december can't
come soon enough now obviously i'd love
to hear your thoughts on the trailer so
make sure you comment below and let me
know as a thank you for interacting with
the video you'll be entered into a prize
draw in which we randomly pick three
comments to win an mcu box set all you
have to do to be with the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the first look the winners of last
month's competition are on screen right
now so that's you then message me on
twitter at heavy spoilers if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out one of our marvel related
breakdowns on screen right now in which
we point out some cool easter eggs you
know you know how we do i don't need to
sell it to you now without the way thank
you for sending through this i mean paul
i'll see you next time take care peace